[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
et bravo à ceux qui ont gagné ce premier
petit jeu
les amis aujourd'hui nous sommes en
Islande
j'ai perché
[Musique]
il est très très beau c'est notre guide
regardez bien pourquoi on est là
regardez bien attention
nous on avait fait une première
collaboration avec Honor une vidéo
cache-cache on parle beaucoup parce
qu'elle vous a beaucoup plu et moi aussi
ça m'a beaucoup plu et cette vidéo
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit arrivera un peu
plus tard en fin d'année mais à
l'occasion de la sortie du Honor 8x que
j'ai ici présent sous la main on leur a
proposé d'aller en Islande pour prendre
des très belles photos avec le téléphone
et surtout on a un programme de malade
on a des activités vraiment intenses
aujourd'hui on a un planning cool on
commence par quoi
magmatique un volcan volcan on va partir
sur la côte sud et on va aller
premièrement dans le Mordor et ensuite
on va aller sur un champ de glace on va
sur un glacier d'accord c'est quoi le
Mordor c'est la pleine qui t'amène au
glacier et ensuite je n'aura pas si
toute la journée au froid et ben on va
rentrer dans les sources d'eau chaude de
islandaise ah oui j'ai vu des photos de
ça
les gens dans des sources il fait froid
dehors mais dans l'autre et bien les
amis si tu pars qui ont une démarche on
dirait que je vais aller volcan G3 j'en
ai jamais vu de ma vie à part quand
j'avais 8 ans et je me souviens le
moniteur c'était moqué de mon famille
parce que m'avait dit que ça venait
sûrement d'un ancêtre qui était un
clochard d'où le nom que je m'appelais
Hochard je vous jure c'est une vraie
anecdote allez c'est parti on y va
les amis nous apprêtons à commencer le
début de ce les conditions
météorologiques sont désastreuses il y a
du brouillard il pleut la caméra on peut
pas sortir plus de 3 minutes si il y a
de la buée ou les gouttes sur objectifs
et je vais arrêter de me plaindre dès
maintenant pour kiffer cette journée en
compagnie de quelqu'un
on va l'atteindre ce volcan on va
l'atteindre
[Musique]
la blague juste
on va plus faire de l'ascenseur ensemble
maintenant que en trois mois à Paris
[Musique]
mec il y a une goutte frère elle est
tombée de tout en haut du volcan et elle
m'a fait très mal les mecs on est dans
un volcan on en parle c'est parti
il y a très longtemps c'est pas nous
mais de la lave qui se trouvait dans
cette chambre magmatique habituellement
elle s'effondent après l'éruption du
volcan mais comme là elle est qu'à 150
mètres sous terre elle est restée bien
en place si on regarde bien on peut voir
pas mal de trous dans les parois par
lesquels la lave ses faux filet jusqu'au
sommet du volcan je suis scotché devant
ce qui m'entoure c'est tellement beau ça
va donner une belle photo
[Musique]
et bah [ __ ] les amis on s'est régalé
non non mais répondez quoi
elle est tellement ouf qu'on ne sait pas
ce que c'est celle-ci bon ça ressemble à
quoi de l'époque néolithique
de l'époque néolithique
on est équipé pour monter le glacier je
suis content parce qu'on a un piolet on
va dire que c'est une pioche
et avant ce jour la seule fois j'ai eu
cette instrument c'était dans Minecraft
et dans fortnite on a aussi une paire de
chaussures avec des crampons pour pas
qu'on glisse comme des cons parce que
bah ça va être de la glace on va
vraiment être sur un [ __ ] de glacier
et la petite nouvelle traîtrise c'est
qu'en fait avant le glacier il y a 10
ans tout là où il y a de l'eau bah c'est
du glacier c'est très triste le
dérèglement climatique bien sûr on est
la cause et c'est un peu triste voilà
il y a plus du tout le monde positif est
cool c'est bon ça va mieux j'adore ce
bruit
alors pourquoi il y a du noir sur le
glacier en fait il s'agit descendre d'un
volcan qui est entré en éruption en 1918
ça fait 100 ans c'est son anniversaire
hier peut-être qu'on peut lui chanter
joyeux
[Applaudissements]
anniversaire
joyeux anniversaire
on va commencer à évoluer
progressivement vers le haut du glacier
on est équipé pour on est un peu comme
Spider-Man attention
bon les amis je prends le relais avec
les GoPro pourquoi parce qu'il pleut
énormément ludoque en PLS il ne peut ni
faire de drone parce qu'il pleut et ni
sortir la caméra parce qu'elle aussi
elle craint la pluie alors regardez le
visage d'un homme frustré c'est
maintenant on voit pas les larmes parce
qu'il a plu mais je suis très triste on
est sur un bloc de glace de 590 m² rien
que ça c'est dix dernières années il a
perdu une dizaine de mètres de hauteur
et sa longueur à 10 minutes plusieurs
kilomètres Sam tu viens de nous dire
quelque chose de flippant
un moulin ok l'eau c'est un filtre dans
le glacier parce qu'il se passe c'est
que si par malheur tu devais tomber là
dedans tu restes bloqué dedans ton corps
fait bouchon et l'eau monte ah c'est
horrible donc à tout moment si là par
exemple il y a polo et je fais ça
il peut mourir mon vieux
pourquoi tu perds les hommes comme ça je
trouve qu'on se rend pas compte à quel
point c'est grave ce qui se passe tant
qu'on n'a pas vu quelque chose d'aussi
gros j'espère vraiment qu'on se
réveillera avant qu'il soit trop tard et
qu'on pourra réparer nos bêtises parce
que là ça devient vraiment urgent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a trouvé un moulin vous savez c'est
fameux trou pas tomber ben non on va
tomber dans volontairement ok ben c'est
faux on va juste descendre un peu pour
voir à quoi ça ressemble
les gars j'ai une photo pas dégueu en
fait on dirait pas si c'est une vue
aérienne très éloignée c'est une vue de
très près parce que finalement
elle a glace me nique mon cerveau c'est
incroyable l'infiniment petit correspond
à l'infiniment grand cette photo on est
là preuve allez je file dans le glacier
à toutes les gars bon blog
[Musique]
tu es prêt
bon du coup vu le temps là en gros on
est dans un nuage est-ce qu'on peut dire
on a la tête dans les nuages sans parler
de la salade parisienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh non on est en dépression vous allez
maintenant on dirait vers notre
troisième et dernière activité les gars
ça va être très détente que vous avez
vos maillots
[Musique]
par jour sur Chatte roulette il a plu de
son contact et mécène et il pratique le
Jumpstyle nocturne pour info par ce mail
on va aller dans une source de choses
naturelles ici en Islande il y en a une
qui est très grande très belle c'est
celle où on va actuellement on va finir
la journée là-bas après avoir marché
aussi longtemps ça va nous faire du bien
aux muscles et encore en plus
actuellement il y a le match France -
Allemagne là on a raté tout le match il
reste que 10 minutes et je veux qu'on se
met dans l'eau avec mon médecin un peu
tu vois à l'aise j'arrive plus parler
mon cerveau le froid oh merde c'est bon
[Musique]
vous me faites un sketch un stop
il me faut attendre mec il fait combien
là deux trois deux trois sur deux c'est
ça qui est bien c'est la souffrance
avant le plaisir intense c'est pour moi
d'avoir des [ __ ]
les mecs plus rien n'a d'importance
il y a plus que moi et cette eau bon
est-ce que tu penses que l'équipe de
France se doute qu'un mec regarde le
match dans ces conditions
c'est que tu vas mettre la caméra ici et
je vais vous filmer votre arrivée et
vous allez attendre 30 secondes ici ok
les gars vous deux ici vous attendez ici
s'il te plaît
c'est bon les amis petit jeu on sort de
l'eau travaux ça fait tous de lait
le dernier qui rentre dans l'eau il
gagne dit au nord c'est au nord Cup ils
ont validé
le respect total allez ça dégage oh il
remet son titre
rien dans la vie maintenant oh là là
bon c'est terminé de la journée 24
heures en Islande ces voyages le plus
court de toute ma vie j'étais jamais
venu est-ce que c'était génial oui
est-ce que les conditions
météorologiques ne sont détruites oui on
a découvert en live le temps en Islande
c'est un délire comme ça change très
très vite à part ça on a vu les belles
choses et en plus la France elle a quoi
bah oui et attendez il faut aussi que on
montre la dernière photo on l'a pas
montré la voici
vraiment un bon téléphone pour se
prendre en photo avec cette tête dans la
fumée par contre si vous faites une tête
différente ça marchera pas voilà on a
fait nos trois photos les gars on va en
Islande pour faire trois souvent des
contes de ça la chance qu'on a c'est
incroyable c'était génial je suis un peu
triste de rentrer surtout je suis très
triste parce qu'on a pas pu faire tout
ce qu'on voulait au niveau de la
réalisation de la vidéo on n'a pas pu
faire énormément de drone dès qu'ils
peuvent plus on sortait le drone on se
dépêcher de faire des plans mais il se
remettait à pleuvoir les capteurs et
biper de partout et on était en panique
sur le glacier merci au nord on va merci
les gens qui nous envoyaient en Islande
c'était trop cool ce petit voyage on se
retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo et n'oubliez pas l'infiniment
petit ressemble beaucoup à l'infiniment
grand
[Musique]